aumenta la atención respecto a la fecha
de retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses y de la otan de
afganistán prevista para el 31 de agosto
el grupo talibán advirtió que extender
el plazo supondría pasar una línea roja
y amenazó con represalias
denunció una clara violación del acuerdo
de doha que pautó la salida de las
tropas a cambio los insurgentes se
comprometieron a no permitir que el
territorio afgano sea utilizado como
base para planear ataques contra eeuu
así se redobla la presión en medio de
enormes esfuerzos de washington y sus
aliados por evacuar a miles de personas
del país el pentágono aseguró que sacará
a todos los estadounidenses en kabul
antes de la fecha aunque no descarta
aplazar la no voy a hablar de manera
específica con las comunicaciones que
mantenemos con los talibanes somos
conscientes del deseo declarado de los
talibanes de tener la misión completada
para el 31 de agosto nosotros también
estamos pensando en completarla para el
31 de agosto de terry first en las
últimas horas eeuu ha ayudado a evacuar
a 16.000 personas y desde el 14 de
agosto ha sacado de afganistán al menos
37 mil francia reino unido y alemania-
llaman a una extensión del plazo que
pedirán formalmente en la reunión de
emergencia del g7 este martes entre los
aliados la preocupación por no poder
continuar las evacuaciones tras la
retirada de eeuu del terreno es cada vez
más grande nosotros estamos hablando con
eeuu turquía y otros socios con el
objetivo de facilitar una operación
civil en el aeropuerto de kabul para
permitir la evacuación de personas
también tendremos que seguir hablando de
esto con los talibanes
entretanto la situación en el aeropuerto
de kabul se torna cada vez más complejas
tiroteos y estampidas dejan ya al menos
20 muertos entre las miles de personas
que han llegado al recinto buscando huir